if you miss what traffic you have messed
with the DNA of Southern California I
just created gridlock through town
pretty much all hours of the day it all
comes from the same agenda get you out
of your car sight of a lot of angry
people who live in the neighborhood
upset over the stupid
I even hate this phrase wrote diets here
in this quiet beach community just
outside Los Angeles residents went to
war with the city back in July over
traffic it all started when the Los
Angeles City Council imposed what it
calls a road diet meaning lanes of
traffic were removed in favor of
building new bike lanes and adding space
for parking some locals applauded the
changes I was really pleased to hear
that they would be slowing down the
traffic through here the commuters were
furious we only have free roads that
connect us from the South Bay to the
west side so when the city came and they
half the capacity of two of these roads
it really just created havoc for us
between John Russo is a local resident
who co-founded keep LA moving a
Community Coalition that's fighting back
against the city's unilateral decision
to reconfigure the streets in a way
that's choking the flow of traffic this
was basically done without any community
input like most of Playa del Rey didn't
know that this is happening it created
just huge backup huge gridlock in the
mornings like what was a 10-minute Drive
was turned into a half an hour so it
literally crushed our local businesses
there was a group of 62 businesses that
were surveyed and across the board
business was down from to the
restaurants to the coffee shop I mean
even like people you want to expect like
the dentist the dentist lost customers
it's part of a strategy known as vision
zero in which the city aims to eliminate
all traffic related fatalities by 2025
the thinking is that eliminating car
lanes will slow traffic meaning fewer
accidents the goal is also to
incentivize more commuters to bite to
work in order to achieve zero deaths
public officials have been doing some
odd things Farook Feigenbaum is the
assistant director of transportation
policy at the reason
Station Road diets are used as what I
would call solution ism whereas anywhere
there is a safety issue we're gonna put
in a road diet and it's gonna solve the
problem it's not really based on science
and it's not really based on empirical
findings so after the road dice were put
in we actually saw traffic accidents go
through the roof we had an average of
11.6 accidents per year on these roads
in Playa del Rey we've gone we've had 52
accidents in the last four months so
we're over 400 percent of the yearly
average in just four months emergency
vehicles can get into town we have video
of ambulances out there on culver sirens
blazing just sitting in traffic because
no one can pull over anymore there's no
place for the people the cars to go to
let the response vehicles through
according to 2013 census data just over
1% of Los Angeles's commuters
bike-to-work 67% of commuters drive
you're taking something from a whole
bunch of people just to benefit a few
people that's not a good cost-benefit
analysis what better way to force people
out of their cars except make traffic so
unbearable you don't want to sit in your
car anymore city planners also hope to
incentivize residents to move closer to
their jobs or if they do have to commute
to ride the city's public transit system
Los Angeles has the third largest
transit network in the country yet only
10% of commuters use it to get to work
in Los Angeles a majority of the folks
simply cannot get from their home to
their job in a short period of time
using transit and it's not an option and
so trying to force people into one type
of behavior doesn't tend to work and
it's why even in Los Angeles the vast
majority of people are still commuting
by automobile in October the Los Angeles
City Council reversed itself in Playa
del Rey after community members filed
two lawsuits against the city and
launched a recall election of local
councilman Mike Bonin who had backed the
plan but the city is still planning to
implement over 40 road diet projects in
other areas of Los Angeles and Chicago
Minneapolis New York and Atlanta are
pursuing similar policies in the 1960s
we were building interstate highways
freeways through downtown areas which
was definitely the wrong approach nobody
is suggesting we go back to that but now
we seem to be on the total opposite end
of the pendulum where we don't want to
build any road
all we just want to build bike paths we
want to narrow lanes we're saying that
transit is gonna solve everybody's needs
neither extreme is what we need to do I
just think this is completely wrong it's
not about cyclist versus drivers these
are all of our roads and they should be
safe for all users and the road diet
didn't make our roads safer and they're
not making it better for the cyclist
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]